[Applaudissements]
plus les jours passent et plus je
m'enfonçais
comme la sensation de man lisez ou de
tomber dans le vide
et de faire une chute interminable les
gens chantaient 1 prenaient en photo
la musique était forte tellement forte
l étouffer le cri de mon âme qui hurlent
et oscour tout le monde dansait chantait
la salle était pleine mais pourtant pour
moi tout était vide vide comme cette vie
que je menais vide de sens entouré de
gens avides de fric de filles de débats
stupides j'étais vite mais je faisais
semblant
semblant d'être bien mais je perdais la
tête de plus en plus je prenais des
cachets de plus en plus je me faisais du
mal de plus en plus et puis je penser à
l'amour de plus en plus mais je disais
je continue à faire semblant
d'ailleurs parfois je me mouille
on était combien faire semblant